la bonne nouvelle est donc tombée hier
soir en indre et loire 43 restaurants
peuvent de nouveau accueillir et servir
des convives en intérieur une décision
prise par la préfecture en concertation
avec la cci et les fédérations
professionnelles du btp afin de
permettre aux ouvriers de manger chaud
et au chaud ce midi les restaurateurs
habilité à le faire remettait déjà les
petits plats dans les grands
mais ce réellement suffisant pour
relancer une activité qui tourne au
ralenti depuis plus de trois mois ont
fait le point dans ce reportage de
romain delville c3 étancheurs sont parmi
les trois premiers ouvriers du bâtiment
et travaux publics d'indre-et-loire à
pouvoir manger officiellement à la table
d'un restaurant depuis trois mois
ça change tout ça évite de manger dans
le camion dans le froid voilà au moins
on est plus à l'abri on est au chaud
mais là ça fait plus d'un an qu'on n'est
pas venu les aider commandes manger aux
camions et puis bon je pense qu'on revit
ici à l'octroi la majorité des plats
continueront d'être emportés la gérante
a compté le bar restaurant peut
accueillir 13 personnes sur place par
service oh non ça changera peut-être pas
grand chose mais ça changera surtout
pour les ouvriers à qu'ils en ont marre
de manger depuis un an dans leurs
camions qui vont pouvoir manger au chaud
c'est tout ce que ça va changer parce
que je pense que on n'aura pas tout le
monde déjà on va respecter les distances
qui nous ont posé à quelques mètres de
là le grillon fait lui aussi partie des
restaurants qui sont autorisés à rouvrir
mais jusqu'à la fin de semaine ce sera
emportée comme beaucoup de restaurants
contacté il attend lundi pour le sur
place pour respecter toutes les
nouvelles normes je peux accepter 24
personnes par service voilà ce que je
souhaite à terme c'est faire de service
pour accueillir 48 personnes
en fait la préfecture a donné son
autorisation et hier soir mais chaque
établissement concerné doit maintenant
signer une convention avec les artisans
ou les entreprises du btp pour
accueillir les compagnons
les discussions ont commencé il ya trois
semaines entre la préfecture la chambre
de commerce des représentants du
bâtiment et des représentants de
l'hôtellerie restauration savoir où
étaient les zones de tension quelques l
entreprise serait susceptible de venir
dans les établissements et quels étaient
les critères de prise en compte pour les
établissements ou bar-tabac brasserie de
l'hôtel de ville à chambray-lès-tours
lundi midi sur place sera hamburger
maison
l'arrêté préfectoral les conventions
sont sur la table prêt à être signé
après trois mois d'arrêt il faut
relancer l'activité comme avant ou
presque
il faut remettre en marche la bière se
réapprovisionner en boisson
[Musique]
la nourriture prévoir combien quelle
quantité on va remettre en route en
cuisine nous faisions des plateaux repas
jusqu'à maintenant mais il est probable
qu'on va remonter en quantité quant aux
règles sanitaires ce seront quatre
personnes maximum par table des tables
séparées de deux mètres minimum et sur
ces dernières aucune salière ni
poivrière ne sera autorisé la sanction
en cas d'infraction sera la fermeture
administrative
et cette fois sans possibilité de faire
de la vente à emporter